pound or bot hacking is so common that
if an email address has never been
compromised there's a chance that it
doesn't even belong to a real person or
that it's been created very recently
it's not hard to check if your email
address has been hacked there are
Services out there that let you see if
your info is listed on databases of
hacked personal data for instance have I
been pwned is a service that contains
7.8 billion hacked email addresses
Meanwhile my phone has 16 billion the
identity leak Checker website shows how
many accounts are compromised daily in
real time if these sites don't show that
you've been hacked there's a good chance
that you're in the clear but you can't
be 100 sure if you're lucky enough to
have an uncompromised email certain
services will offer to notify you if it
happens so you can quickly change your
password to be safe regularly change
your passwords don't open strange
attachments and always check the sources
of any emails you receive check to see
if your email has been hacked and let us
know in the comments